hey everybody what's going on is the
camera messed up and the lights messed
good to me no I think you got it
seriously I think you got it yeah I
think you got
it me that looks all right I think that
looks good yeah I mean I thought it did
too but you know you weren't in here so
okay past couple uh reviews we've been
actually you know not any reviews on
some of the shows too we've been talking
about uh some of the hammer horor
vampire movies yeah we were watching
Christopher Lee well I was looking at
what uh hammer horror films were
available on uh I think it was on it was
on this might have been on Amazon Prime
Amazon Prime I think I saw this one
Batman versus Dracula the Batman the
Batman versus Dracula animated yeah I
was like man that sounds like a good
idea if it's done right so uh and I like
some of the I like the animated uh um
superhero movies uh especially the
Batman ones I liked I really liked Red
Sun that was a good one too that was
Superman right communist Superman yeah
that's a good one didn't we we did Mask
of the fantasm right did we uh I don't
know I don't think oh wom yeah that was
that other Superman movie wasn't it no
Batman Batman yeah I man I forgot about
it now I know we've done a few animated
ones I remember us doing Red Sun
oh yeah yeah mask of the fantasm I we
have to see it again I forgot it yeah I
want to see one that has Bane in it yeah
but uh there are certain aspects of
superhero stories that that really only
come across an
animation I mean the Christopher Nola
movies I thought were really good uh the
old Superman movies you know Superman
one two and one to four you know three
wasn't that good four was [__] [__]
show but I loved it was Canon film
but they still can't capture animation
you know what what it was like you know
the certain character powers and [__]
certain things that happen in superhero
stories really kind of only make sense
in
animation so I was like I want to see
this
one we watched it and I thought it was
really good I thought it was really good
this was a lot of fun I thought it's a
straight it's it's a a very good vampire
story and it's Dracula it's not the
Dracula yeah the dra it's Dracula and
Batman knows who Dracula is I mean it
it's a pretty involved story and it it
shows what would happen you know almost
kind of like a what if well here it is
you see it this is what would happen
when Batman has to deal with a vampire
and not only any old V he deals with a
bunch of vampires and
Dracula and uh it's pretty awesome
the The Joker and the Penguin let him
out he was buried in Gotham Cemetery
like not on purpose they did it
accidentally yeah they accidentally let
him
out uh he they took he was hidden in
Gotham City's Cemetery you he he did
even even TR didn't know how he got
moved there but his yeah they never
really explained that do they just said
oh that must have happened after I died
and then just kind of how he got there
you know he was there in this big
Vault they let him out and
uh one of the first things Dracula does
is he turns the penguin into a thw yeah
he doesn't turn him into a vampire
vampire turns like a like a daylight
servant yeah and he decides he's going
to turn all the Gotham City into a into
vampires yeah I mean why not right and
now he eventually turns the Joker into a
dra into vampire too that's that's
pretty which I was not expecting that I
was not expecting so you get to see what
would Joker would be like as a vampire
it's pretty crazy and
uh well cobblepot you know or uh penguin
penguin he tells he tells Dracula about
Batman and uh he he starts vibing with
this Batman concer so he's not the only
man that takes the form of a bat you
know that kind of [__] so uh Dracula
goes on this damn vampire [__] crime
spree and Frames Batman people think
that it's Batman that's doing this that
Batman's the vampire it's like making
all these people disappear making these
people disappear and and it's pretty
cool um
Bruce Wayne meets Dracula at a party of
course and Dracula [__] him up mind
warps his ass because he's got mental
Powers uh all the weakness a mortal
would have Batman has it but he tries to
overcome it he does overcome it he comes
up with some good ideas I don't want to
spoil everything about the movie but I
think it was a good movie I liked it it
was a solid vampire movie the the
Dracula character had a lot of good
lines he did a lot of cool [__] he he
could uh he had different looks when you
first see him he just looks like a damn
bones and then he comes out and he looks
like a looks like an evil ghoul for a
while and then he finally turns into you
know kind of a swaave kind of guy but
when he goes when he goes straight
vampire he he almost turns into a
superhero himself really which is right
along with the theme of the mo of a
superhero movie they show what a fight
would be
like Batman really didn't stand a chance
but he he I mean he gets his ass kicked
ass kicked but he he does eventually
which he would it's Dracula yeah he does
eventually uh defeat
Dracula yeah I mean obviously yeah oh
murder Hornet has come back to flash
bulbs welcome back to flash murder
Hornet yeah Danny Rings said the Batman
year One cartoon uh two-part Saga is
also really good with Batman voiced by
Peter Weller as an old Batman okay also
Larry Brown says love this movie The
Batman is a great animated series as
well happy to see you guys talking about
this one yeah we just just kind of
picked it randomly cuz like I said we
were going through all the bat all the
um all the Batman movies all the Dracula
movies because we were doing a bunch of
hammer Dracula this was in and this was
just kind of we were just searching for
all the Dracula movies which of which
there were many and so this one turned
up and Tom's like that sounds pretty
cool we should actually like watch that
yeah I recommend it Danny ring said
there's a Batman film where it's an old
school Batman from the 1800s where he
goes against Jack the Ripper AKA
Commissioner Gordon as Jack the Ripper
it's there I want to see it and there
was also a samurai Style yeah it's on
there also I think that's all of yeah
most of that is on there samurai Batman
but yeah I didn't even realize cuz I'm
not real up on um all the comics and
everything like that so I didn't even
realize that Batman the Animated Series
and the Batman were two separate
animated series I'm not sure when Batman
the Animated Series was on the Batman
which is what this is spinning off of
was I think 2004 to 2008 so that's in
this universe so I guess like the other
one because isn't Batman the Animated
Series isn't that the one that has Mark
Hamill doing the Joker I think so cuz
this one is is a different guy I don't
know them all I don't either I've only
seen a few of them and and by chance I
picked him at random and this is one of
them and I like this one a lot if if you
like vampire movies this is a good
vampire movie and if you like Batman and
you like this is a good Batman movie too
yeah they did kind of some cool [__]
with this I really liked I mean I like
the concept I don't think this is the
first time I think there was when I
looked it up there was a comic I think
it was called red rain where Batman
fights Dracula but I think Batman turns
into a vampire in order to fight him
which is also a good option he doesn't
do it in this one though but it's like I
like that so you also had the like the
Penguin and the Joker both in this and
like at the beginning you kind of think
well do you think the Joker gets killed
but the Joker in this one is not the
same I guess the same in Universe joker
as the one that's in the other animated
series cuz I remember that one being
different he doesn't look human yeah he
looks kind of like way crazier in this
one like he's got like a big like his
hair looks like a Jester hat kind of and
he like runs around with bare feet all
the time and you get one of the best
sequences in this is when after Joker
gets turned into a vampire because he
does he goes to rob a blood bank and
then Batman has to go fight him at the
blood bank and like the way they shoot
it it's really cool it's just like black
and green like with all these like big
stripes and everything like that like
the visuals in this were really cool I
thought yeah um and I thought too that
you know the guy that did the voice of
because I was watching some other
reviews of this and this seems to get
like pretty decent reviews across the
board a lot of people kind of quibble
with the guy that did the voice of
penguin um which I think is also the
same dude that does SpongeBob I thought
he was fine I think I think it's Tom
Kenny yeah I thought he was fine yeah I
mean some of the jokes are kind of like
Dad jokes or like kind of puns and stuff
like that but it's just kind of like I
liked this because it's like it seemed
like it was aimed toward kids kind of it
was fun for the whole but it was also
yeah but it's also like adults could
really enjoy it cuz there were some
parts of it that were like legit scary
there was just kind of like really scary
imagery in it they actually like people
actually got shot at which um I heard
that the other uh episodes of the
Animated Series you know they would just
shoot with like lasers and stuff like
that but this one seemed like actual
machine guns and stuff like that you
know what I mean yeah cuz I think like
Batman was getting shot at by like a
[__] SWAT team or some [__] because
for a while they thought he was the one
kidnapping everybody because people were
just like I saw this big bat and then
and then the person disappeared the tone
the tone is kind of it does have comedic
relief uh Cobble pots kind of funny and
so it is kind
of kids would like it and it's not so
much that it turn off an adult and then
it would get kind of more serious like a
like like an old school Universal
vampire movie or something yeah even a
hammer vampire movie but it was animated
and it would kind of there'd be some
more comedic relief here and there I
just thought it was a it was a decent
mix for the whole family you know mean
if you could just you know an adult man
could watch it I watched it I thought it
was cool you know you can get away with
a lot more on an in in an animated story
that's true you know you're more
forgiving of the tones because one thing
I thought was kind of interesting like I
said as far as it being geared toward
kids which I guess it sort of is but the
sequence that I was talking about before
where Batman fights Joker in the blood
bank that's actually had they used red
ink instead of black for all the blood
that would have been like super super
gory yeah because I mean Joker is just
kind of like covered in blood at at one
point yeah he was trying to drink it all
up yeah he was like trying to drink it
all like out of the bags and everything
and it's like I guess that's how they
kind of get around stuff that's like
well we'll just make the lighting such
that you know the the blood looks black
so it doesn't look quite as alarming
like with this red blood flying
everywhere it was a trip Batman was Dr
he he eventually captured Joker and had
him in a in a
cell and he was begging for blood he was
dying for it and uh to try to control
him Batman was giving him little bags of
his blood he was taking his own blood
giv it to him he wanted to know wanted
to know where Dracula slept I don't
think he ever gave it up though did
he he I think you know what
he did yeah in the end he did I think he
kind of said it um it was enough to
figure out inadvertently yeah enough to
figure it out right cuz the thing about
it is that like I said they don't really
explain and it doesn't matter it's a
cartoon for Christ's sake they don't
really explain like how Dracula got
there like Dracula basically just said
oh well a [__] must have happened after
I died they showed a quick Montage H
being placed on on a boat on a boat or
something like that well because he was
ashes yeah right because that was how
cuz didn't penguin like find him in the
vault
well I guess he was kind of like a
skeleton he kind of he was like a
skeleton and then he bled on him yeah
he'd been cut he trying to pry thought
treasure was in there yeah I thought it
was he priming it open with that um um
with a crowbar no it crar it was his
umbrella had a blade on the end of it
right he slipped and cut himself and it
went onto that body and he turned his
back on it and walked off and it started
to grow back and it stood up out of
there and it freaked him out they were
scared of it which is kind of cool the
the uh
The Joker and penguin were scared
shitless of it they didn't know the
vampires were real well I mean I guess
you wouldn't yeah because you know
they're super villains and everything
but they don't really have Supernatural
Powers they they never seen they didn't
realize that Undead existed right and
can I say I really really liked the
Dracula in this he was super cool yeah
cool yeah I knew I recognized that voice
I'm like who the [__] voice is that
cuz I know I know that voice it was
Peter stor and he was was in you would
probably know he was in a bunch of uh
Cohen Brothers movies he was in the big
Labowski he was in um Fargo he was in
Constantine he was in Nacho Libre yeah
he's been in a [__] time he's a big big
[__] big Swedish actor so yeah so um
so he had that accent so I was just kind
of like man I know that [__] voice
and I was trying to like place it but
then I found out who it was afterward I
thought it was a tight flick man and
good voice acting good story uh kept me
entertained through the whole thing uh
wasn't any boring spots in it which is
that's one of the good things about
animated stories there's there's no dead
time in it you can't have a boring spot
really in a animated well you probably
could but it would it would suck you
know what I mean it has the
same the the the the story moves along
at a at the speed of reading a comic
book and you know we're used to these
superhero Stories being told to us in
film like like they're realistic that's
not how they originally were like when
back in the 70s when you were a kid
writing them they reading those comic
books was more like watching this that's
what it was like well I I can kind of
relive it like yeah that's that's what a
comic book's like I think that's why a
lot of the people that like the comics
like these animated ones because it is a
very similar experience you're right so
yeah but you know like I said this isn't
really the first time I guess in the
comics or anything like that that
they've done this Batman v Dracula face
off but you know and I haven't read the
red rain one that uh was supposedly
based on that but I like I liked how
they did this because I said I like the
fact look if Batman like what are you
doing she's pulling all the books out of
she's like you guys are not paying
attention to me so I'm going to pull all
your books out of your bookshelf so [__]
it yeah she's doing it um I like that
I'm sitting there thinking how is Batman
who has no Supernatural Powers all he
has is like a [__] ton of money and like
all these gadgets and stuff how would
you fight Dracula who has all of these
Supernatural powers
and I like like I said red rain I think
they went the route of Batman becoming a
vampire also so he would be on equal
footing which is also a good idea but
they didn't do that in this one I like
the fact that they used like Batman
Bruce
Wayne's Tech skills and his money and
stuff like that to kind of solve the
problem you know what I mean like I like
that they went that route with it
because it was like very in character so
it was like in real life like Dracula
would just whip his ass and he did whip
his ass like several times I really
liked the fight too between Batman and
Dracula like on the rooftops or whatever
cuz I thought that was cool as hell like
Dracula has this cape but it wasn't like
a regular like all one piece Cape it was
kind of like all these pedals or like
yeah it l it almost looked like
tentacles or petals or something like
that so like every time you went they'
kind of go like like octopus tentacles
and I thought that was like a really
cool I thought it was a really cool look
yeah you know yeah well in the spirit of
of a comic book movie an animated comic
book movie you can't have dra you can't
have Dracula as a static [__] figure
like you know Bella like Bella legosi or
he he's portrayed as basically a
superhero or super villain yeah he's
doing a lot of the same super villain
he's kind of like Superman in a way evil
Superman he can move extremely fast he's
he could Dodge he anything you throw at
him he can dodge it he's got powers of
Mind Control did he turn into a bad at
any point
I don't think he ever Chang I don't
think he changed into a B I don't think
he would like could shape [__] no I
don't think he shape they didn't address
that but he could I mean and he could
vanish into his Shadows though yeah yeah
he could do that he was getting ready to
kill Batman one time the sun came up so
he just moved back it was cool the way
they drew it yeah I like that he went
into a into a um in between two
buildings into a uh Alleyway and there
was still a little bit of a shadow there
and you could see his eyes glowing in
that shadow and then uh when the sun
came it all just kind of faded away yeah
that was really cool it became one with
the shadows and then vanished along with
the shadow it was was that's that's a
hell of a vampire trick to just vanish
into a shadow and and then the shadow
van vanishes like that's pretty [__]
cool yeah I really yeah I really liked
that whole like see the look of that and
I also like too cuz here was the thing
like this is good storytelling because I
think that they really built this up
really well so you not only have you're
kind of just run of the Batman villains
you know you got Joker and you got
penguin that you got to deal with and
then they both kind of throw in their
lot with Dracula at some point too but
then you also have to contend with
Dracula making other vampires yeah he's
got an army of them and like yeah so
like every and this is kind of going by
because I know vampire Laura is
different from like medium to medium but
this one is going on the thing that
everybody that he bites turns into a
vampire too unless he kills him unless
he kills him and eats but it seemed like
like he was mostly just keeping them
like for a vampire AR well his mission
was to turn all goam City into a city of
the undead so he was yeah that was his
whole so he was he wasn't drinking them
or killing them he was just biting them
yeah so his numbers would increase he
didn't turn penguin into one though no
he just kind of made him I guess he just
needed one dude to like do [__] in what
he said yeah he said he was going to be
a servant yeah did it with his eyes he
didn't have to give him any blood or
anything yeah it was like a hypnosis
just hypnotized him and he was a willing
servant and everything he he's kind of
cool a
thraw he's kind of funny yeah he's kind
of a comedic character and he he simps a
lot you know for for Dracula simping for
Dracula you know that was pretty cool I
want to write a novel called Sing for
Dra yeah it's it's it's it's a gay porn
Noll called although I guess they've
already made that movie and it was
called
Renfield Dracula cuz he was pretty much
simping for Dracula yeah although he
stood on his own two feet in but uh also
Vicky Veil is in there that's right and
of course you know Dracula's got his
eyes on Vicky V is going to make her his
vampire bride well sort of kind of yeah
but I also like he then going to take
her [__] soul and use it to bring his
first wife back yeah I like that they
also
Incorporated Dracula's bride and it was
Carmela carstein yeah so I was like so
they knew they they're vampire and
here's the cool
thing they they let him bring Carmela
back without totally killing Vicki Veil
so you could see it happen yeah but then
they they stopped the procedure you'll
if you watch the movie you'll see what
I'm talking about yeah so it wasn't like
they're just going to tease bringing
Carmela back they do just that she's not
back for long yeah uh because they would
kill it would kill Veil if they did it
and they can't do that they can't do
that so um another thing that was about
the movie that I liked it had a whole
bunch of Easter eggs in it they called
they they called all the the people had
been turned into vampires they called
them lost Ones kind of like The Lost
Boys yeah uh what else vampire [__]
Aster eggs kind of stuff in there all
kinds of [__] one thing I alard they
call that's that's Easter egg that's
what I was gonna say so the thing about
it and here's the thing and I know this
is like I said a little bit geared more
toward kids and stuff but it's like so
Dracula shows up at this big party that
Batman is giving that Bruce Wayne is
giving yeah it's in all the Batman
movies yeah he's always
a big charity ball or whatever so he's
got that going on he's eating steak
Tartar and [__] yes right well I thought
that was kind of funny because he's just
like o steak tartar you know what I mean
like cuz he's
Dracula but then Vicky was like oh I'm
like hey you [__] serve that like why
are you get alled what was cool about
that part of the scene is that that that
scene was shouting out to the old scene
with bellosi where they're trying to
whine and d and be polite you know
before right before they
call they call Dracula out by trying to
trap him getting him to look into a
mirror they did something similar to
that Batman knew that it was Dracula
well he well that's what I was going to
say but it's just kind of like so all
there had been all these mysterious
disappearances around Gotham and then
this um unusual Eastern European man
yeah shows up looking very much like a
vampire at this party called alard say
saying his name is alard and I love that
Batman or Bruce Wayne rather had to
write alard like a tray and put it in
show the audience he had to show the
audience they always do that in movies
I'm like do you not like can you not
just do that in your head like e egg why
you have to like they got that from
other other vampire movies I I kind of
thought it was great cuz the kids
probably hadn't seen that one and the
adults would [__] understand be like
the adults are like okay yeah I gota
although in real life if Dracula was
real which he may be we don't know but
I'm just saying that if Dracula was real
um you'd think that he wouldn't just use
like different iterations of his name
like if he wanted to keep on the
download you know what I'm saying it's
just like you could make up a whole new
name yeah no one would know there's an
audience you got to worry about you got
there's an
audience in real life if there was a
real Dracula and he was worried about
getting staked or whatever the
identities of a victim yeah you'd every
80 years or something you'd have to go
through a process and like change your
name and all this other kind of [__] so
no one would catch you you can't just go
around being like I'm Dr Acula you know
like Ed would you know I mean you can't
do that kind of [__] CU it's like
every's like you're Dracula no no I'm Dr
Acula nothing to do with Dracula nothing
at all so
um they offer Dracula some more derves
and he goes oh yeah steak of tartar he
eats that but he didn't eat the bread it
was on was on a cracker he eat just
immed he's like oh you know like that
and Bruce Bruce Wayne had the other
trade he goes here here's some here's
some garlic shrimp he's like and he's
like he goes it has quite a punch she's
going oh you [__]
you so I like it yeah so I thought it
was like funny it was just funny because
it seemed like with through from that
whole exchange it seemed like Bruce
Wayne was like [__] I know you're a
vampire you know what I mean but then
the fact that he had to write down alak
card on the thing and like put in the
mirror and show it to Alfred you know
what I mean it's like look at this you
know so I just thought that was kind of
funny also I like Alfred was like pretty
proactive in this I liked Alfred in this
too like he was he helped out a lot like
I think he even got kind of his ass
kicked a little bit by vampire they
showed the Batmobile but only briefly it
was you only see it from the back yeah
only see it from the back and it looked
like some kind of badass futuristic
Corvette they never really showed the
whole thing I wanted to see I wish it
had a scene with that a driving scene
but dra didn't have a vehicle so you'd
have to chase him and you know when they
were chasing Drac he was chasing him on
foot flying around chasing him yeah so I
guess there was no call for the
Batmobile but you know at least they
showed the Batmobile yeah I mean you
kind I maybe they're contractually
OB but the thing about it is that like
like I said in real life and you know
Dracula's not real I know but it's just
kind of like if Batman was chasing
Dracula I don't think he'd be able to
catch up with him just running maybe
you'd have a better chance in a car is
all I'm saying you know like using a car
to chase Dracula because you wouldn't be
able to like but you'd run after him he'
just go or he'd fly or turn into a bat
and fly away or whatever the [__] I
don't remember if he actually he kind of
flew in this one didn't he who Dracula
yeah he could have her yeah he seemed
like he because he was kind of flying
around and like on the you know what I
mean but like I don't think he ever
turned into a bat though but there were
like a lot of bat and he basically
teleported away when he vanished inside
that shadow yeah that's right and he and
he could do that like where he could go
like and then like turn up behind you
and [__] like he could do that he could
teleport by locate and [__] you can
bucate Ben says um they made a couple of
these animated films with Vicky Vale
after the Batman movie She's a totally
two-dimensional fake girlfriend in mask
of the fantasm obviously a bit more
involved in this one yeah she was
actually in this one quite a bit because
she was um you know reporting on the
case of all the disappearances because
at first like nobody knew it was going
on like nobody knew that people like
people weren't turning up dead like oh
my God a vampire bit them you know what
I mean so I kind of liked that too
because in a lot of vampire movies in a
lot of Dracula movies you have a thing
where you you have the van helson
character being like let me see their
neck and oh my God it's Nas veratu or
whatever but they didn't really do that
with this one that's why nobody knew
what was going on because Dracula was
just biting these people and then just
keeping them in his underground layer
like as his little armies they were like
little vampire zombie type people yeah
so nobody so nobody knew what had
happened to them it was just all these
people disappearing so nobody was
turning up dead so nobody knew like
exactly what was happening with the with
the yeah when they turn in this one when
they turn to vampires they don't look
like mortal humans anymore yeah it
looked more like a ghoul although Joker
still had his mental fat well whatever
mental faculties he had I think the
other ones did too they were just
obeying yeah I guess they didn't really
do too much with they because they
mostly just kind of seemed like Monsters
yeah cuz like the first one he turned
was that security guard guy right and
then like that that woman that had like
her purse snatched or something Joker
stayed the same he just looked different
too yeah he just looked more like
vampirey was like drinking blood out of
pouches and Stu just so he was acting
like crazier but he acts crazy anyway so
yeah and and Joker didn't look like
didn't look human before he was uh
turned into a vampire in this in this
story anyway he looked more like
a like Eddie from [__] Iron Maiden or
something yeah he got like this big
weird teeth and like like a face that
almost kind of looks like a like a mask
he kind of looked like the comedy
tragedy masks that's kind of what his
face looks like kind of looked like like
the Predator mask to me oh yeah a little
bit like with the hair yeah with the
hair and a predator M just you know but
he had a mouth you know but I'm just
saying he just he looked mechanical or
something Tammy said yeah just call
yourself Jeff Vader right well I know
like um The Welcome to the basement
blame society guys he had a long running
series what might still be going called
Chad Vader that was like Darth Vader's
like middle management brother or
something like that I don't remember but
yeah Eddie isard does a bit about about
like [__] Darth Vader in the
cafeteria the Death Star and stuff and
it's really funny uh Ben says Count
Dracula is a title so you could call
yourself that for centuries that's true
yeah but it's just kind of like I don't
know I would kind of want to if I was
Dracula um I would kind of want to keep
[__] on
the on the down low so I so I would just
kind of like change my name every 80 or
so years just means count Dragon you
know it's all it means so yeah it's not
quite a
name his real name was Vlad vladish or
sepes yeah well that just means the
Impaler yeah sepes that wasn't really
his last name that just meant the impal
is that okay yeah and then um it's from
my understanding I don't speak his dad
was dra yeah and he was drul ya son of
the Dragon son of the Dragon yeah yeah
but these are titles
yeah Danny ring says GTH Vader that's
the country music version yeah or Vlad
the inhaler yeah that's the asmatic
vampire but yeah I mean I definitely
want to watch some more of these
animated uh superhero things and like I
said the Batman versus Dracula like I
kind of feel like maybe I don't know to
us we were like hey that sounds pretty
badass and like some people would be
like that sounds really stupid it it
wasn't stupid it was super fun I want to
see the V I want to see the Victorian
the Victorian Batman I want to see the
Jack the Ripper one yeah I definitely
want to see the Jack the Ripper one cuz
I love that kind of [__] see we'll see
it I wonder if it's on is it on I it's
on it is it's on Amazon Prime yeah what
was it called again did he say what it
was called uh something dark something
or other it's you man it comes up if you
just serve for
Dracula Batman Batman or forgot what
it's called okay so maybe that's what I
would do you can tell just by the the
cover what it
is it's got people with like top hats it
looks real uh Victorian looking yeah see
I'm into that kind of [__] yeah now see
Danny Rowling says the Batman Beyond bat
suit is on the level of the Predator's
armor which could toally take out
Dracula easily the Batman Beyond suit
increases strength has invisibility camo
and he can fly with it okay oh well see
that's really helpful almost like Iron
Man yeah cuz like this I think the suit
that he has in this one is just cuz it
seemed like he wasn't flying he was just
using his using his string or whatever
what's a good Bane story that has Bane
animated yeah because you guys know a
lot more about this than we do cuz I
just kind of see these intermittently so
I don't really know all the I know
there's at least three of them that have
ban of seen three different
designs Ben says there was an episode of
Super Friends where Dracula
Frankenstein's monster and the mummy
were zapping people with eye beams that
controlled them I think I remember that
cuz I used to watch Super Friends it had
something to do with the Easter Island
heads yeah yeah I think I know by gas
light that's what it's called that's
right okay yeah we definitely we
definitely got to watch that cuz that's
like right at my alley I I would love
that kind of [__] I love all that
Victorian yeah Jack the riv by gas light
nice
yeah Dan ring said Batman the Animated
Series uh has a lot of Bane episodes so
yeah so that was so that was a different
so can we can you rent the entire
animated series or buy it maybe I
imagine you probably can probably buy
cuz like I said I didn't even realize
until we watched this movie that Batman
the Animated Series because I'd heard of
that yeah but I didn't know that the
Batman was a whole different and I think
it ran for like five seasons this the
one that this was SP well they do that
they reboot a lot you know what I mean
people do it just I mean you might as
well there's so many
pretty want that last movie was called
the Batman right I saw it and it made
the impression that it was a it was a
good movie but for some reason I wasn't
getting into it at a time I I need to
maybe watch it again yeah that was the
Robert pson right Pon like I was the one
like this is okay but it just didn't
really didn't really grab me like uh
yeah I liked it but it didn't really
right but maybe I didn't give it a
chance I don't know I mean we'll
probably watch it again at some point
cuz I like to give things to sh it's
really hard to beat Batman Begins for
that movie there for Live Action I
thought Batman Begins was great I I like
all three of those
movies those C are no weren't you
watching weren't you watching villagers
react the other day and they and they
thought that was like the best thing
ever yeah those dudes thought made in
the whole history of the world they said
that whoever directed these three movies
is it what do you call it an incarnation
of God says this is great the best movie
of all time I wonder if anyone's ever
sold Christopher Nolan that like if
anybody ever s him like a
video they were all into [__]
Batman analyzed it and everything so
this was the villagers react like the
one with Baboo right babo yeah okay cuz
there's two different ones that we watch
yeah they they one of them is two
younger guys yeah and then I think that
one's called ciles react or something
like that but then there's one called
villagers react yeah and it has this
like really old this really old guy that
they call Baboo yeah and he's just with
various other people which I don't know
if they're his relatives or just other
people he knows or something like that
but that dude is like [__] and he
sings at the end of every single one
they'll [__] put subtitles or love
songs and
[__] then the uh what was funny is that
to watch
those Watch the watch people who who
don't know the Mythos at all and to see
their interpretation like for instance
in that third movie from Christopher
Nolan they didn't know who Catwoman was
so they just kept calling her that Thief
girl they didn't know who
that's really F and they didn't know who
that cop was they didn't realize they
didn't know that was Robin right you
know yeah cuz they didn't they didn't
know the they don't know the story well
like I said they don't really know yeah
um and she was never called Catwoman as
far as I'm as far as I know in that last
movie they never call her that and they
never call that dude
Robin yeah but everybody here would know
yeah everybody here knows what that is
like everybody right with any cultural
awareness at all Jess aynn says Batman
the Brave and the has a Vampire episode
and also Ben says for horror Batman you
need to watch the Doom that came to
Gotham H which animated I reckon it is
okay I yeah it's like I knew that there
was a lot of animated properties like in
this whole um in this whole thing but
it's like I didn't realize the extent to
which cuz I mean this one this didn't
play in the theater or anything it just
went right to DVD it did yeah like when
I think when Batman Begins came out yeah
did that on in 2005 something like that
this when this came out that yeah this
came out in 2005 so this just went right
so it was just kind of like trading on
that yeah that big movie coming out and
he's like here we're going to do this
animated one but they just did it right
to DV yeah what else information you
been a to dig up on it um not a huge
amount like I said it got like sort of
decent to mixed
reviews um oh I looked here they said
um yeah elor's comic book Batman and
Dracula red rain that was when became a
vampire to fight Dracula there were also
two knockoff films which I think maybe I
want to say they were Turkish called
Batman Dracula and Batman fights Dracula
but of course they had nothing to do
with right yeah because Turkish the
Turkish will the Turkish will just
that's a whole new world of they just of
fun they just steal [__] they have no
idea what the stories are about they
just go yeah what was the Spider-Man's
always a bad guy I know yeah yeah well
did it like the yeah the Turkish
Spider-Man like they have other titles
that's just what people over here call
them cuz that's what they are but um
didn't one of them have like Spider-Man
like a green suit yeah it was it was red
and green it's red and green I think it
was just a color treatment they didn't
they didn't just got it right got it
wrong I think maybe I I don't know what
they were doing well it wasn't even a
two-tone yeah you know cuz the
Spider-Man one was red and blue but it's
just kind of like I think this one was
just all green had the same design on it
you're not sure if he's a good guy or a
bad guy he does both he goes to strip
clubs he's just you know fing B it's so
we it's just baffling a lot of because I
kind of feel like turkey more than any
other country I feel like they're kind
of they will just take any big American
movie Star Wars Jaws whatever and
they'll just like do a $5 ripoff of it
and they're usually like hilarious
because they've usually one they there's
no budget and it's like they don't
really have much of a grasp on what was
going on in the original movie yeah so
some of the stuff they come up with is
just whole scenes like still whole
scenes of Star Wars yeah of the [__]
Death Star scene and they'll even steal
and then they'll be running [__] raos
the Lost Art soundtrack in the
background at the same time it's pretty
epic Fu
great yeah no no respect for copyright
they don't give a [__] yeah they don't
care well yeah like Brandon tenold has
done a bunch of reviews of some of the
Turkish I think he did Turkish Batman
Turkish Spider-Man yeah uh Turkish Star
Wars T like I said they have titles but
that's we call that's yeah that's what
people call him over here also um I
found out there was an early Batman
villain called the monk who was a
vampire and that was like from back in
the 30s huh okay so it's not I mean it's
not really crazy because I mean you know
dra like Batman dresses like a bat
obviously so it's just kind of like a
man bat so it's kind of like a vampire
thing so it's not really as weird as it
sounds I guess but you know I don't know
I I really liked this a lot and like I
said it made me want to watch more
I kind of like more I don't know if I so
much like just like the regular ass
stories like it's just you know set in
the modern day or whatever but I kind of
like when they do something weird or
like alternate universe with it I think
that's really cool like I said I really
liked that red Sun yeah like what if you
know what if uh Superman had landed in
Soviet Union in the Soviet Union you
know what I mean like that's I like all
those kind of what if scenarios or like
this kind of thing where it's like a
weird monster mash up I'm kind of like
any that kind of stuff cuz it's fun you
know they kind have like the title was
enough I'm like yeah Batman and Dracula
yeah check this out we're going to have
to watch that we're going to have to
watch that and it didn't disappoint yeah
it ended up being really good like I
particularly I thought the fight scenes
in it like the way that the the fight
scenes were um were edited and laid out
and stuff like that like looks really
cool I thought yeah very anime inspired
editing very anim Ed up its game you
know it's not like old school [__]
Spider-Man that you saw on television
you know the old animated Spider-Man was
Hannah Barbara no who who did did that
man Spider-Man Spiderman boy that
terrible that might have been hannar
bear I think it was hanar Bear maybe
yeah it was just like the gel the the
the a couple of frames [__] you could
tell it was the what was it gels yeah
the way the [__] moved it was just like
stupid real
two-dimensional but it was you know
classic
[__] Danny Rowling said on YouTube
there's a Batman fan-made short film of
him going against predator and winning
it was pretty cool and done well just
saying all right so yeah there's
probably that's a whole another you know
can of worms you could open is like all
the fan-made stuff like that's on
YouTube so if you want how would Batman
do with the with the
xenomorph I kind of feel like H I kind
of feel like anybody would get their ass
kicked by a xenomorph but you know maybe
not how would Superman do with the
thing oh yeah now there's a mashup I'd
like to see could he stop it yeah well
if anyone could stop it he could but I'm
not real sure well what would he do if I
mean it would just I don't think it it
couldn't absorb him I don't think well
why not cuz [__] he's [__] He's org
he's organic though still right yeah I
don't think he can get sick but I don't
think that matters I think that just the
fact break his skin though I don't think
that thing could hurt him that he's made
of organic yeah but it could like get in
his mouth or up his butt or something I
don't know no I'm just saying I don't I
don't think the thing could take over
Superman now we're going to have an
argument over whether Superman over
whether the thing could take over
Superman I think he'd be IM but he
wouldn't be able to he'd be trying to
save everybody else true and how could I
don't know I he would couldn't figure
out who was who well see that's the hell
of it that's why the thing is the scar
and always will be the scariest monster
yeah I think because there's no way of
knowing like who's the thing and who's
not and then by the time you find out
it's too [__] late you would think
something like that might actually exist
in nature on another planet but I don't
think so it would be here already maybe
it is no no no cuz it would have taken
over the whole world by now yeah we've
talked about that before when we talked
about the thing and this well actually
they even addressed this in the original
John Carpenter movie where they said how
long it would take for yeah pretty much
it to take over the whole entire world
yeah so like not even that long I you
know what though it's just Superman like
I said he's not a person he's an alien
but he's still an carbon based life form
right I would imagine so I don't know I
think the thing would be able to would
be able to replicate him Ben said have
you seen the Yugoslav Captain America
movie Steve Rogers and the Red Skull are
were both from a small village in Italy
it gets weirder after that wow see this
is like there's a whole world out there
of like these crazy [__] mashups that
just make no sense and they're kind of
wonderful Bollywood Batman
yeah Batman versus Judge Dread Comics
are
[Music]
good oh okay Danny Rowling said I have a
Batman comic book that shows Batman
getting his arm ripped off by some type
of creature that resembles the xenomorph
and wins well the wait a minute so he
gets his arm ripped off does it grow
back no he's Batman he's not a lizard
man so he has to just like he has to
kick a Xenomorphs ass with one
arm [__] man does he beat the xenomorph
with his own severed arm
yeah coming like Jeremiah
Johnson be
meeting a [__] with another
[__] or beating a [__]
with your own [__] like your own
[__] leg or some [__] like that they
they did that in Renfield too and that
like that part made me laugh like that
fight scene where you tore up that
dude's arm it was just wailing on
somebody with the arm that like cracked
me up okay I got to get going okay oh
that's right he's making some eggplant
he's make some eggplant lasagna later on
yeah all right so that'll wrap it up for
this review uh hopefully you enjoyed it
we will see you again on Wednesday night
this is kind of like our pre it's like a
while before Halloween still but it's
just um it's kind of our pre- Halloween
show so why don't to do something spooky
so what went in the poll was more ghost
ships so I love Ghost Ship story so I'm
going to I got a whole bunch of new ones
that we're going to talk about that we
didn't talk about we did a show like uh
sea monsters and ghost ships like a long
time ago but I managed to get like some
different Ghost Ship stories this time
around so we're going to talk about that
on Wednesday night so hopefully you guys
can join us so again thanks very much
for dropping by have a good day tomorrow
and we'll see you guys again on
Wednesday night good